the Buddhist psychology tradition in
particular and the Asian psychology is
in general and actually the ancient
Christian monastic psychologies do have
a strong theory and a strong practice
really of overcoming bitterness hatred
resentment vengeful notes and so forth
carrying a little further from Moses's
already restraining idea of an eye for
an eye a tooth for a tooth in other
words you don't take a leg or a life for
an eye you know or a life for it tooth
you know just another tooth which was
already a step forward from the old
vengeance idea of tribal attitude and
and Jesus's and Buddha's greater idea of
really love your enemies and how to
unpack that in a modern city and people
get nervous about it because they think
if you love your enemies
you're mean it means you're gonna cave
to them you're gonna be a martyr you
would invite them to come and destroy
you and just be a masochist and so forth
and that is not at all what it means
love means in the Asian psychological
term and I think really in any term
means the wish for the beloved happiness
to want to make the one you love happy
that's what love really is it isn't
really greed and wish to possess
although some kinds of love center tend
to mix with that of the egotistical
person the reason someone is your enemy
is they think you're preventing their
happiness somehow you have something
they want you're in their way whatever
it is the world isn't big enough for the
both of you type of attitude and so
they're going to be your enemy because
they're unhappy and they think by
getting rid of you they'll be happy so
if they were happy already without
messing with you they might be wanted to
leave you alone because it's no fun to
go attack people it's like it's an
exercise you know it's not like giving a
caress or receiving one so so loving
your enemies is actually practical
advice and Martin Luther King for
example when he went back to second time
to that bridge in Birmingham John Lewis
says that he he was advised by his
friends come on don't get into how we
gonna love those guys those cops who are
sticking dogs and hoses and beating us
and jailing us and torturing us and then
Martin Luther said no Martin Luther King
said no it's too bitter a burden too
hatred and resentment we do love them
of course we oppose them and we are
against them and we don't want them to
behave like that but we don't hate them
that's just a ridiculous waste of our
energy and in a way you can say that
being an enemy who has hurt you has
already hurt you if you go around
nursing hatred and vindictiveness and
how to get back at them you're hurting
yourself when you oppose your enemy who
someone and an advice by saying your
enemy someone they think they're your
enemy hopefully if you love your enemy
you have no enemy but if your when you
oppose that person which you could do
you can have tough love you can have
fierce compassion and you when they
sense that you're doing it because you
want their betterment actually because
it's not good for them to be mean to you
and so on then actually it has a little
different edge to it and for example if
you're trying to get them to see reason
there's a better chance they'll be able
to listen to you when they don't feel
the weight of hatred and a destructive
vibration toward them coming through the
speech you know what's in this style and
the energy of the speech your motivation
will make it more successful